Marvel Comics has some ridiculously
overpowered characters you've got Thanos
with The Infinity Gauntlet Franklin
Richards Matthew Malloy any one of whom
can alter the fundamental structure of
the universe turning anything into
anything else then you've got the
molecule man Owen Reese you've got the
beyonder who can basically alter the
structure of the Multiverse above them
you have the Living Tribunal and even
the one above all who was believed to be
the most powerful being in Marvel Comics
but all of those guys pale in comparison
to the power of a girl named Miranda who
only appeared in one story arc and her
level of power was so extreme not even
the one above all could undo anything
she wanted to do she could create
anything out of anything and give it an
entire history she could wipe something
out of existence and his entire history
would be destroyed as well she was by
all standards of measurement a stand-in
for the Riders and the editors and the
artists in Marvel Comics make sure you
guys check the comment for a link to the
video